hi my name is Farah and my name is Diego
and we're here to present computational
thinking chain reaction used to show our
kids how it is to interact between the
physical world and work from language
using physical computing and having fun
- yes
hello so my name is Barrow and my name
is Diego yes and we are here to present
you a computational thing in chain
reaction I think it's the first and so
the biggest we will see order you have
seen before and I hope that it
established record to be bitten on
future conferences we use Goldbergs
idea about coming up with a very complex
or indirect way of triggering a workflow
to execute a very simple task so that is
indeed the purpose but well the
motivation is a little bit more
fundamental is that well we learn with
experience and extraordinary language to
to experiment with the real world to do
computations directly with a real wall
but well communication protocols
sometimes are daunting and in some way
we'll use this presentation to focus on
the different ways you have to
communicate between the different
technologies about what the most
important thing is I think mathematic as
a sorry the Wolfram language is a great
tool for kids to start experimenting
with physical computer in the world so
yes so we're gonna start it's a chain
reaction we're going to start with a
using an old phone and user setting it
up as an IP camera to capture livestream
we will take that image will look for
any much of an animal using web you
might search let's use the network from
image identify to figure out what it is
we will use the new Wolfram channel
framework to communicate between one
computer to a Raspberry Pi we have the
raspberry
I send an inquiry to the wall from cloud
to get us to send us that what that
animal is through MSS SMS through a
Waldron sent message on my android phone
I got Pascal which will then post the
data into wall from the drop we will get
that data from Walford drop the search
on wall from alpha for the scientific
name of the animal then use the Sigma
communications method to send a data to
Arduino and then we'll just as a tribute
to Morse send it on Morse code for you
all to see nothing can go wrong
yes yes it's really well basic stuff
so what we have here it's well it's when
when Diego said it's an old phone yeah
well it's an Windows Phone yeah yes push
the bar little bit higher yes so what
you have here is a standard IP camera
software you can add it in well I phone
iPod Android phones we have a lot of
apps for that thing and what it does is
that heat it starts transmitting a
streaming of images and so one small
detail here is that of course for all of
these to work all of this has to be
routed into the same network in this
what I mean is that we have there a
small router that you can see in on top
of this table that is actually where all
the devices are being connected because
of course trying to connect this through
the conference center network would be a
little big to to to down ting for us and
say yeah so let's try and find a cat an
image
and if everything goes okay okay first
step is is working we hope it is
gathering images of cats okay why a cat
well why not a cat yes it's the internet
that we are searching for so obvious
it's a cat has to be all right so what
we're gonna do is come to the image of a
cat and so for that we are using a
little piece of code developed by our
not a little bit harness that is in the
room a little bit adapted because we are
sending a stream of Mg peg through the
IP camera and what this means is that
well we actually can transmit from an IP
camera directly to mathematica in a
pretty nice way yes and so we are on
second step now you don't believe it so
let's let's try to have Anton Anton for
oh sorry
Anton for posterity okay so what we are
now going to do is that we are going to
the previous slide and point it to the
cat yes let's try to have here a
beautiful image of the of the cat and we
are going to remove the task that is
constantly updating under streaming and
that's it so we are I think 20 percent
done and it's going okay so we have this
image that was captured and we are going
to try to identify it and please yes
let's see let's get to at least 50% yes
and so
I think at this moment we have the world
record yes now to make it a little bit
easier to transmit between all those
technologies we are using a string and
not an entity but that's just for
convenience because well at a given
moment we are going to send an SMS yes
so well now well before we send it so
one of the things that we did is there
is a new experimental technological
channel framework which makes it
extremely easy to pass information along
from one mathematical instance to
another so my friend Pedro has set up a
raspberry pi over there do you want to
show it sure through the screen I think
we are already transmitting and so we
need to make sure that we have it set up
and yeah sorry you passed it okay so
what we are seeing here at the screen
it's it's the Raspberry Pi screen it
doesn't actually exist physically on the
Raspberry Pi it's it's headless in some
way but we are accessing it through a
VNC
and we already have loaded Mathematica
just because raspberry pi is a little
bit slow and so just make sure that we
would get to the 50% and so we already
have here a notebook opened and the
first thing that we are going to do is
to actually Cloud Connect I already did
it just in case that it would break here
and so we are sure that well raspberry
PI's you need connected to the network
and everything is working and what we
are going to create here is a listener
for the channel that is called Wolfram
technology conference 2018 and I think
we're now ready to send a message right
yeah we are ready to send a message yes
you know yes it was just to make sure
that it connected okay
you could indeed go to the menus and and
and asked to connect to the cloud etc
but on the Raspberry Pi Steve this thing
to do is to use the comment and so here
we send the animal name that's the
variable animal but well you do remember
what is a name it's yeah let's just send
it and did it appear on the mmm well we
do count here one message it's very
small it's a very small number but let's
see if it got yes it went through so we
are probably at forty percent yes so
already hard to beat in default on my
team so what are we going to do now well
now we are going to call an API function
that was preloaded into the Wolfram
class that is prepared to send that
extremely important information through
SMS to well let's say modern mobile
phone and so well let's try to do it can
become yeah so let's see if indeed God
LarryBoy image capture let's go for it
send it again yeah so control the year
okay so we can see undergone a new and
new SMS and go very quickly from one to
the other one very well okay I came
through so yes so we did send Tommy a
stick cut string into an API function in
the cloud that in itself sends SMS
through the phone and within the phone
yes within the phone using Android
you've got many possibilities so we just
pick the most complicated one because if
not it wouldn't be a Rube Goldberg
you got the IFTTT which makes it very
simple a welcome technologies does have
a
plug-in to send it to the drop but that
would be making it easier so we just
went for the complicated work using task
so you will see in the documentation
basically what it will do
there is a task over there it gets an
SMS it checks that it's from Wolfram
cloud and then what it will do it's
basically do a posting into the data and
so we do suspect that it is already in
the data been that incredibly important
message so let's check so let's define
being as being the data beam that was
preset that is often data technology
conference 2018 and let's get the last
information that went into it and so
thank you so yes so now let's try to get
extra information on what is a domestic
cat so we do contact go from alpha to
have the information from it and well
what would like really to have so the
purpose of all these was actually to
have the scientific name of the animal
that we streamed video streamed on on
that particular strange phone and so we
do have already the scientific name and
now we are going to the hardest part all
right so we already have the message
that we want to transmit on the airwaves
and what we have here is a little box
that you will see the breakdown on the
screen it's got a little radio in there
the other radio is connected to the
computer and we wrote a little function
that would translate the message into
Morse code so these are just functions
that allows us to transmit these
information you want to go to the end of
the room so yeah
so we just connected the device
attention hmm because these are is going
to be last face let's see if you can
really live with the scientific time no
way to do okay he doesn't believe me so
why don't we send it again yes so let's
send it again and let's actually do an
image capture at the same time and and
and Anton is going to kind of prove that
it is being transmitted let me just try
to yes
yeah he's holding the cat so let me okay
and I can you can we can
what he didn't see it so turning around
okay good okay
and say yes go ahead please yes yes well
yes the cloud is actually it's actually
because we are using the API function
from from the Rockland cloud and so I
had to connect the respect to the
porphyrin cloud that's one and the
channel neck the channel framework it's
under Pedro's ID so to be able to open
it there has to be a user involved and
with the with the Raspberry Pi sometimes
we would load it and there will be no
user associated so we just made sure
that uh yeah that's beyond we all my
paper I think
outside that as long as you have a
broker of yourself yes that is if you
are going through broken technologies
you have to pass through the Wolfram
cloud but you can actually have some
let's say server listening to your
message and distributing your message
locally and that is completely doable
yes yes yes and you even have although
from even has MQTT protocol although on
a very Alf base but it actually works I
have tried it before and so yes you can
actually create a small server just to
receive and distribute message within
your local system yeah that we wanted to
it's just because it's a Windows Phone
and you have anything against it just
download an application something really
just to make it harder okay and so well
well it has to be serious and so the
purpose was pushing the envelope of
Internet cat image computational
thinking yes because that's one of the
main purpose of the Internet so we left
some code here for you to you want to
see it yes and so well coming back to
some basics because we do still have
some units and so what have we used well
we have used or we are still going to
use in this demonstration an esp8266
that's a microcontroller it's
very similar to the Arduino that we have
used inside that box that has those has
the LEDs and so that's not really
computer it's a microcontroller it
doesn't have an operation system it just
runs again and again again the same
instructions and we have used risk
Raspberry Pi that we're actually
Mathematica was running with these
devices we can do a lot of interesting
things
Diego is here demonstrating something
that should be impossible but it's
actually quite quite simple and so just
for the people that are not in the room
let's see if we can capture so that's an
ESP h's u66 it is just connected to a
battery bank just for convenience it
could be just connected to any kind of
battery yes but like that we avoid
cables and it's quite secure and what we
have here is a moisture essential and a
soil moisture sensor that would
eventually use to know when well when
your plants are needing water and so why
this would be possible to do actually
yeah so looking at the documentation
there is no UDP channel to use within
Mathematica but what's the problem we
got a external evaluator so let's say
the code is in my room why not
copy shamelessly so we went to item
really the Python program just for the
reference despite encoded a code it's
actually within the notebook so if you
download a notebook you have it as a bit
array stream inside the notebook so that
you can save it back to a file if you
want go ahead and write something out
see how human
and so we can actually transmit
information even with channels that
Mathematica doesn't necessarily support
from the start because well we have
external evaluation with Viton we have
external evaluation with JavaScript and
I don't believe it so you don't believe
it so Dutch no good and so let's just
kill the dynamic so let's make sure that
yeah yes just one because why not yes
yep we will wait for your table next
year
for sure it will be very interesting and
so just to finish because we still have
a couple of minutes to go we have a
different one here so this one it's
again using esp8266 as a microcontroller
but we are going to send the information
coming from temperature and humidity
probe to vote from technology directly
from the esp8266 with a post on the data
on the data being infrastructures and so
well it has been actually it has been
transmitting from the beginning of of
this talk because we just plugged it and
it should be working fine and so what we
are going to see its how hot this come
on the last one so thank you so let's
see now come here
now you can now you can use your breath
because it's good a humidity sensor so
go on it
come on keep keeping it it's every 15
seconds
yes it's every 15 seconds that's every
50 seconds so I think that where we are
going to see a difference is in humidity
generally immediately not yet not yet
not yet it doesn't want to refresh well
well Brian yes now I have the scheduled
tasks running and for some reason maybe
it's dead okay it just moved and it went
up immediately didn't Intuit us up as we
would expect but it is ended up sighting
because the graphic just update is a few
more seconds and that's basically it
thank you thank you
[Applause]